this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode he's going to be taking a
look at the weapons from void
interactive's tactical shooter ready or
not now as we're looking at extreme
detail the primers are visibly dented on
all six of these fresh rounds that have
just been loaded they shouldn't be they
should be perfectly smooth and flat
because they're meant to be indented by
the firing pin to fire the round
jonathan will be revisiting ready or not
in a couple of weeks time so make sure
to subscribe if you're keen to check out
the second episode later on and if there
are any other games guns or mechanics
that you guys want to see jonathan break
down let us know in the comment section
below right let's take a look at the
guns of ready or not
all right mp5 and we've got an a4
which is the fixed stock
like this one i put this one together
for the video
and the burst fire capable trigger group
it's what makes this and this an a4
although i'm not sure if the game calls
it an a4 or not this one's been modified
clearly and i don't i'm not up on mp5
accessories but that is an m lock four
end of some sort and what looks like it
might be a silencerco
suppressor i'm ready for a torrent of of
your wrong comments on that one and that
looks like a trijicon srs which we
actually do have in the collection but
not
on an hk claw mount this this is a
firearm was released in 1966 when
optical sights provision was minimal it
was there
and so
if you're not familiar the hk
the traditional roller locked hk um
roller delayed hk firearms have these
shapes pressed into the metal
that take what's called a claw mount
because it looks a bit like a claw and
that means you can adapt this legacy
weapon to modern optical sights which is
what we see here and that's absolutely
fine that trijicon is i don't know i
haven't seen one in use in a while um i
don't know how popular they are in us
swat teams and we have a fairly
traditional vertical foregrip attached
to the bottom of the railed handguard as
well overall our old favorite the mp5 is
depicted really very well here i think
in terms of modelling and textures
it's up there with the best that i've
seen the sound effect sounds right
and it looks to handle
okay as well
now something that's often discussed in
the context of law enforcement firearms
is penetration specifically over
penetration and i'm not gonna weigh in
too heavily into that debate except to
say that nine millimeter ball ammunition
such as fired by the mp5 will happily go
through
wooden doors drywall
it's more penetrative than people
think so by
sticking with pistol rounds doesn't
automatically mean that you're going to
save an innocent person on the other
side of a thin wall say you have to
think about ammunition choice barrel
length there are all sorts of other
factors to consider now but there is
this sort of received wisdom that pistol
rounds are less likely to keep going and
hit people
that they shouldn't so it's good to see
in the game certainly that door is not
posing any issue to nine mil rounds
they're going straight through as of
course they would in real life
unarmed
wow well that's that's a very effective
breaching shotgun that has uh
not only
opened the door but utterly destroyed it
i don't know if it might need a bit of
tweaking there now the door was actually
breached by that first shot taking out
the the door handle and that might be
enough uh we then see the the player
attempt to take out the hinges
so in theory if you if you were to like
blow both hinges and
kick or bash the door down it goes and
your and your team is in in this case
three shots was enough to sort of
disintegrate the door into bits which is
perhaps not not as clean as you might
wish just seeing a breaching shotgun in
a game is a thumbs up though because um
most games just don't accommodate the
weapon as a tool
in this context the breaching shotgun i
believe this configuration that's in use
so this is a mossberg 500. now normally
a shotgun with no butt stock is a really
bad idea any
long gone without a butt stock you'd
better have a very good reason for
having it because
you are instantly less accurate with it
now in this case it's because you're not
less accurate with it because you're
placing the muzzle at the hinges or at
the lock and you are using ideally a
special breaching round a frandrable
type ammunition that in theory is less
likely to go through what you're
shooting at and hurt someone so it is in
this context a tool a piece of equipment
not intended as a combat weapon i guess
if you came through the door and somehow
the team failed you and all you had was
this
of course you're going to try and use it
but those frankerble rounds will not be
the most effective
anti-personnel
round going
so less than lethal we do have a number
of tasers in the collection at the royal
armouries they are firearms adjacent but
they are non in theory non-lethal or
certainly less than lethal so the
version depicted in the game and it is a
true taser taser is a much abused term
usually applying to just about
everything that has electricity in it in
this case it's an actual taser the
version in the game is the m26 a
civilian version that came out around
the same time was the m18 and that's
what i have here because it's the
closest thing we have it's the same
simple polymer frame
capacitors and replaceable
co2 cartridges containing um the wires
that spool out we see that in the
footage there
and they are sort of coiled like that so
the depiction of the of the probes and
the wires coming out is is pretty good
and we also see the reload press and
remove the expended cartridge
click in the new one so it's pretty good
there are a couple of sort of queries i
suppose one is the visible blue
electricity now that has to be a
gameplay element because you can't see
electricity well you can but not in this
context when the two probes hit you see
nothing so i do i do take issue with the
blue the blue flash the response of the
suspects two being hit as well now i i
have not been tased but the developers
i'm pretty sure could quite easily
arrange to be tased and when those two
probes strike and make sufficient
contact or near contact of the skin for
the electricity to pass through the body
you go rigid totally incapacitated
usually you fall to the floor as a
result of that almost always and then
depending on who you are how you're
built how healthy you are how determined
you are you recover sometimes worryingly
quickly from what i've seen sometimes
you are so exhausted by all your muscles
tensing up at once and then relaxing
that you are out of the fight here it
makes them stop fighting but they stay
upright they don't tense they don't
plank so i think i think that needs a
bit of work maybe maybe some reference
footage or you know
go and get tased guys
that wouldn't be a tactical game without
some ar-15 variants this is maybe the
most classic now they're calling this
from the selection screen an m4a1 it's
not an m4a1 um it is i believe a mark
18. so it is basically an m4 but with
the short
entry length barrel so for you know to
try and approximate the length of an mp5
basically the version we see here has
got a more modern butt stock on it and a
quad rail handguard but it's the same
basic weapon as this it does fit the
bill a shorter barrel you don't really
want to be like the old-school lapd swat
in the 70s had full-length m16a1s i mean
that was considered a short weapon in
those days but not something you want to
be busting down doors with today when
you have better options available and
ammunition options that can claw back
some of that effect some of that
terminal effect that lethality that you
lose with a shortened barrel so of
course you're going to see a weapon like
this
in this situation let's see how it plays
the weapons get on the ground now
hands up make them secure
all done contact is secure right i've
got the footage paused just to get a
good look at the
ammunition here now i don't think i
think types of rifle ammunition are a
thing in this game at least not yet the
rounds shown are
visibly green tip so that that would
usually mean that they were m855 a us
military type of 556 ammunition it's not
armor-piercing per se but it has a
reasonably hard
penetrator inside each bullet and it
emphasizes penetration over any other
effect that's an interesting choice for
for this scenario because it is going to
increase the chance of a bullet zipping
through somebody and hitting somebody
else behind i might expect to see
actually hollow point ammunition some
sort of expanding ammunition which
although illegal for land warfare is
pretty standard now for law enforcement
so that's a nice detail in terms of
including the tips on the round i'm
guessing it's that's the ammunition they
had to to reference to make this but
it's maybe not the best ammunition to be
simulating in a law enforcement context
suspect killed
minor point and it's not weapon specific
but we're not seeing
picking up of enemy weapons there's an
absolute trope of first-person shooters
at this point that you can at any point
just abandon the weapon that you've
trained on that the department in this
case has paid for and pick up some
random person's gun that may or may not
function may or not may or may not be
accurate may have all sorts of issues
with it it's
absolutely right that the mechanic here
is instead to secure that and take it in
as evidence maybe you wouldn't wrap it
up for forensics there on the spot but
that's a ready indicator and game that
that weapon has been secured so you
don't pick up enemy weapons you secure
them so you are stuck with the weapon
that you enter the map with and the
ammunition you enter map with that's
what we like to see
all done contact is secured drop the
weapon
ready for trailer
so some of the the um shall we say
legally different markings on things are
only obvious if you look for them if you
look at them in the the gunsmith
part of the game some of them however
are right in your face and this um
eotech
site that actually says leotech leotech
for i presume legal reasons is is quite
noticeable but not so noticeable that it
takes you out of the game which is of
course the art in doing this kind of
thing and it's also quite clever because
leo is an abbreviation for law
enforcement officer so leotech makes
perfect sense
slightly strange choice for a modern
tactical
shooter of this nature is the colt
python which is what this is so a 357
magnum revolver same as this one instant
drawback of only six shots okay it has
stopping power well i think we can all
agree that uh 17 rounds of nine
millimeter is probably preferable to six
rounds of 357 whatever you think of the
stopping power argument and if you are
having to shoot at people wearing soft
body armor chances are it's going to
stop this however um i wonder if this is
a bit of a nod toward the french gign
they don't use pythons but they do use
the manual
mr73 or at least they still have them so
that is one sort of
elite special weapons and tactics type
police sort of units who have favored
this type of revolver and back in the
70s absolutely you might find swat teams
using them certainly found detectives
using them for that additional
penetration but not really a viable
choice i would say it's big it's long
it's heavy you only get six shots that
said i really appreciate the attention
to detail with the reloading when
the weapon runs runs dry because the
rounds stay where they are the cases
stay where they are because they're
fired cases but you can continue to pull
through on the trigger and the cylinder
revolves with the empty case is still in
it clicking merrily away doing
absolutely nothing most games will just
have it go click nothing will happen you
won't actually see it follow through on
the trigger pull
like that so i do appreciate that level
of detail i also recognize the need for
variety with with sidearms pistols are
an important part of a game like this um
if the game is correctly set up
there will be times when moving through
close quarters with a pistol might make
sense more so than a military shooter
where it's just a backup weapon so to
give you variety so that you can fully
make use of the sidearms i understand
why you might why you might include it
now as we're looking at
extreme detail a carryover maybe from
the movie world where this happens all
the time the primers are visibly dented
on all six of these fresh rounds that
have just been loaded they shouldn't be
they should be perfectly smooth and flat
because they're meant to be crushed by
the firing pin or dented by the firing
pin to fire the round we should only see
all six primers dented when all six
rounds have been fired now that would be
a really minor detail if it weren't for
the fact that we have a equivalent of a
chamber track which i really like the
fact that they have press checks in the
game the player character is checking
effectively the primers on his rounds to
see what he's fired but because they're
all fired it's a completely pointless
gesture it doesn't show you how many
rounds you have left so there is
actually a gameplay consequence to not
modeling fired versus unfired private
games not finished i imagine that's
something they're already planning to
include
this is almost literally a simply a
spicy paintball gun this is a if you've
been a paintballer or know your
paintball guns this is a titman a5 with
the air bottle set up in the
under barrel configuration so it is
literally a paintball gun it'll be uh
0.68 caliber only instead of projecting
balls of paint
it's uh irritant it's a you know a
chili pepper or capsaicin
extract inside it is a powder and it
bursts into a cloud it's extremely
unpleasant it's another option in the
less than lethal toolbox it might take
several shots to achieve the same sort
of effect it's something that might
persuade people to to rethink what
they're doing you have a
psychological effect of being shot at
and hit by something and then you have
the stuff that gets in your eyes and
your throat is not pleasant but the
actual delivery system with a couple of
exceptions
is not even a modified paintball gun
just a re-branded paintball gun in fact
tax 700 is
a real designation for one of these
weapons from a company called pepperball
who
may be the most prominent providers of
this kind of thing if you're thinking
that looks like a toy mp5 that's because
the tipman a5 is inspired by the mp5
and are refusing to cooperate
all right well i feel i can't criticize
the inclusion of an fn fal or foul if
you prefer
in any game because it's pretty iconic
standard
service rifle of the british army for
many years i know some of my friends and
contacts would would hate me if i said
why is this in this game however
yeah i mean i know why it's in the game
it's in the game because it's cool and
because it's a 762 by 51 punchier more
powerful
rifle option now there are others you
could have gone for it could be like an
ar10 pattern type or sr25 pattern it
would have been it would be perhaps the
more likely they're not really that
common as an entry weapon i mean this is
the right length to be an entry gun
762 or 308 in law enforcement usage
these days is typically a marksman's
rifle it's a bit too loud and concussive
for use indoors even if you really want
the terminal effect of the full power
round it's a bit much even for the
operators
that that especially in short barrel
form that's gonna that's a real
noisemaker it's a
somewhat outdated dare i say this is the
ds arms version with a a nice solid
railed top cover on it hence the big
screws down the side because that's
rigidly fixed in place one of the legacy
problems with the with the fnfal over
here get down
i see a
civilian um so uh ostensibly the reason
for having this big bore rifle as it
were or relatively in the game is to
give you i mean it's clearly an
increased recoil you can see that but in
theory every shot should be a fight
stopper but we did just see a
center mass shot at quite close range
with 762 and the guy
did not stop people people haven't
will continue to do all sorts of
incredible things in terms of injuries
but um i think you'd be going down with
any any
shot to the chest area with with this
caliber that's really the only reason
you would use it
if you'd like to check out the royal
armouries youtube channel alongside
this one uh please do we also have
various of our own social media outlets
and three rather nice museums that you
can come and visit and as ever if you'd
be kind enough to donate to us we don't
require it by any means but there is a
link in the description thanks again
guys
[Music]
[Music]
you